clinton campaign
paid to infiltrate trump tower
white house servers to link trump to
russia okay now who would do such a
thing because she's a very you know
she's always been known as a sweetheart
so
lawyers for the clinton campaign paid a
technology company to infiltrate
servers
belonging to trump tower
and later the white house in order to
establish an interference
and narrative to bring to government
agencies linking donald trump to russia
filing from special counsel
john durham says okay and for the last
three fourteen this is the durham
connection let me go and for the last
four years everybody's been saying
durham's gonna find nothing durham's
gonna find nothing there's gonna find
nothing well he did right okay durham
also writes that during former clinton
campaign lawyer michael sussman's trial
the government will establish that among
the internet data tech executive one and
his associate exploited
was domain name system dns internet
traffic pertaining to
a particular healthcare provider
trump tower donald trump central park
west apartment building and the
executive office of the president of the
united states so john durham is saying
that hillary clinton essentially
hired a company
to have a link to russia even though he
wasn't doing it to say he is it's a
setup now as a person who's a former
economic hitman like yourself
who you've gone and you've sat down with
prime ministers and you've said if you
don't do this things are not going to be
good for you can you see anybody
deceptive enough in politics that would
ever do such a thing to our former
president donald trump
absolutely not we have a clean system
here in the united states why would we
why would we even consider that anybody
would do something so
so
dastardly yeah i mean it's just
i figure you're going to say that
because the level of nobility in our
politicians is just incredible right
semi-saint status now here's what i did
i still want to get your thoughts on
this i want you to type in durham um
uh what do you want to put durham
investigation okay and then and then put
durham investigation and that's it
that's all i want you to put take the
rest of it out and then go to news type
in news okay so watch this uh why does
it do that way
uh go back to all go back to all at the
top
all right let's can you make it a little
bit bigger so we can read everyone how
they titled it
so your favorite word cnn uses the same
word they use against you
special counsel durham alleges clinton
campaign lawyer use data
to raise if you can click on that so i
can read the rest of the title
to raise uh
suspicious about suspicions about trump
right now go back and let's read the
next title
the next one is from new york post xdni
radcliff expects more indictments in
durham's
russiagate probe fox news says clinton
campaign paid to infiltrate trump tower
white house service linked to trump to
the hill
durham alleges alleges cyber analysis
exploited access to trump white house
new york times court filing started at
fewer in right-wing outlets
but their narrative is off track can you
go to the wall street journal which is
an independent source that you know just
happened uh w as there you go trump
really was spied on okay and people
trust wall street journal because it's
typically in the center that's an
opinion piece though yeah i know it is
an opinion piece i read that as well but
you so what is it what is going on i'll
tell you what's going on yeah so so
there's four pillars of the economic
hitman strategy i've been writing about
this the chinese are using movies
all right so so the first
is is fear
uh fear of another country fear of
whatever
the second is debt
the third is uh debts like the debt
loans yep money pure debt
fear debt
uh
anxiety over insufficiency we don't have
enough we need to sell our oil to the
other companies so we can have better
education so on and so forth
and and the third is divide and conquer
and as time's gone on
these things have changed so during the
early times and this is those those four
pillars have been there for them say
these four again or no there's fear
death anxiety over insufficiency divide
and conquer right okay and those have
been around for a couple of thousand
years that they've been used in one way
or another
and and in the in the past most of
our history was mainly fear and it was
actual invasions and or fear of invasion
it's like fear-mongering yeah like the
old pirate thing you know the the jolly
roger going up but what we're really
getting into these days is the last one
which is divide and conquer
and right now in the united states we're
having this incredible experience of
divide and conquer so the republicans
and democrats will never agree on things
i mean it's just like
it's like it's it's it's it's uh
it's a very incredible tactic that's
that's making america appear to the
world is highly dysfunctional and that's
what's happening on the other hand the
the
let's call it the autocratic whatever
you want to call it governments like
china are looking very good to a lot of
other countries in latin america and
africa and so on because they can
accomplish something
and i think that's that's actually why
why trump was so popular for one of the
reasons because he seemed as though he
was moving on a track where he would
take command he would he would do that
kind of stuff
um
so i think what we're seeing here
is that divide and conquer it's like
hillary's doing this trump's doing that
the republicans are doing this the
democrats are doing that
uh it's a breakdown of a system yeah but
there's a difference
john there's a difference here's the
difference and both of you guys are more
on the same side than where i'm at with
this because i'm very skeptical about
what this is all about here's the
difference
john
not a single outlet
needed any information
to go out there for three years talk
about
trump was linked to russia they needed
no nothing was confirmed
for three and a half years that's what
they convinced america that that's what
it was they had nothing there was no
allegedly it was it is
certainty
it's happening he's with russia he's
team putin he's putin's puppet everybody
said it with certainty and america
believed no
no you want me to go play the replay the
greatest hits you want me to bring you
the greatest hits well you don't think
that's what was happening i i don't
think i don't think all of america
agreed by any means oh yo of course
america didn't believe because america
doesn't trust mainstream media of course
but what i'm saying to you is 99 of
media that's all they talked about
that's right that's all they taught and
they convinced
the people a lot of them that this was a
real thing going on now here's the thing
trump hadn't done any of this stuff
right okay a lot of this stuff okay
allegedly yeah
yes but you know that so it's a huge
distraction so what are we really
dealing with in the world today we're
dealing with a very dire circumstance
that that one digress john no digress
i'm not you're digressing i'm i'm right
on point with durham you're digressing
you're going to a completely different
place right now where i'm where i'm
going to
is the idea that the united states is in
is locked in a battle with china our
economic hitman strategy their economic
hitman strategy then hillary's team
china is that what you're saying okay
you're right i'm saying all of this is
distracting us from that that's not the
point does that no no let's stand on top
i agree with you i agree with you that
china's winning i don't disagree with
you and and what are we doing we're
getting distracted by by the way
we're such a great player
i don't i don't agree with you and i'm
not also getting distracted by the mask
thing the vaccination thing there's so
many things
that's like saying that we can't um do
two things at once and there's a lot of
things that we're going to be doing at
once the china thing like for me for
instance the bigger distraction i think
is ukraine to china i think we should
stop focusing on i think ukraine has a
lot of smoke and mirrors that you
brought up that putin has maybe allied
with china i think that's a european
thing the eu nato they need to take over
what's going on ukraine
i don't think united states needs to
mess with it all what i will say about
this
and i
uh very much was guilty of the trump
narrative because for years and years
and years trump trump putin puppet
everything pat
but what they're saying here
is actually
a scandal of the highest proportion if
it's true
if this is true
this is way bigger than water grade for
years and years and years they were
basically [ __ ] on trump saying that
he was putin's puppet and believe me
trump did nothing to help that with his
secret meetings and you know tru
russia if you're listening and all that
he didn't do anything to help him
but basically if this turns out to be
true and right now it seems like they're
throwing this guy michael sussman under
the bus don't be surprised if he turns
into the next jeffrey epstein wink wink
so but if this is true
and hillary did do this and did
plant what what's the use of the word
infiltrate trump tower and did put that
in there and then she tweeted about it a
couple days before the election if this
turns out to be true
this is watergate of the highest
proportion and you know what as much as
it pains for me to say this trump might
have been right
he might have been actually
correct when he said that they were
spying on his comp campaign because one
of the last interviews he did with 60
minutes what's the the the the name
she's like come on uh president trump
you know that's not true he's like no it
is barbara stahl i believe is her name
yeah
i'm not a trump fan
and part of the reason i'm not a trump
fan is because i've been spoon-fed this
misinformation about trump
about about russia much like most of
america but if it turns out that that
hillary actually did do this
she's got some explaining to do yeah so
let me ask last point
it's not just me
66 of democrats according to this poll
66 percent of democrats want hillary
investigated over russia gate yeah so
it's pretty interesting what's happening
out there and last thing if i put into
youtube
youtube because the articles are a lot
easier especially with mainstream media
to write put it out there boom it's done
you put it into youtube
it's only fox news that's covered this
story so either fox news is just doing
what they do riling up the base or
they're actually the only news outlet
that is actually covering this so am i
making sense here yeah but let me ask
you both so what is the significance of
this in the in the long run what where
uh
what what what's what's the potential
outcome sorry john what's the potential
are you kidding me so let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question
do you think the billionaires who are
illegally using crony capitalism methods
to hurt people should they be held
accountable wait we this is a diversion
from the question i'm about to get to
your answer though do you think they
should be able because that bothers you
a lot what these billionaires are doing
you bother with the three people that
have fifty percent of wealth which what
you're saying more than the bottom fifty
percent of wealth right that bothers you
yes okay
the same way that bothers you this is
the ultimate
ultimate manipulator because you're
you're saying who cares if something
like this i know i'm about
accountability i did not say who cares i
say where is
what is the logical outcome of this of
this if she is doing that she needs to
be held accountable and go to jail truth
accountability and that's what she did
because whoever scared the crap out of
the next person the same thing the same
thing if trump did do it yeah you can
truth accountability and penalty if he
did true collude with russia that's
exactly what had been accountable to him
true but the same thing should be for
clinton right if this turns out to be
her totally agree truth accountability
and what's the penalty and we're on the
same thing with lobbyists crony
capitalism taking payments all that yeah
yeah no accountability is the key that's
the main thing because totally once
again you know how people say
transparency you know how people say
stuff like i don't trust my vote means
nothing my vote is
if there's no accountability here people
are like my vote means nothing no i
totally agree with you i mean both of
these yeah that's that's why i asked so
what is the final outcome of this
can we get at the truth and if we can
get at the truth
will the system
punish whoever's whoever i don't think
it will i i that's the problem that's
part of that i don't think it will
that's part of the problem
and as you said as adam says if it's if
trump's the problem he should be held
accountable if hillary is a problem she
should be held accountable but will they
be held accountable even if we do
discover which one is the the the
reality is and this is what pat always
says that what 12 percent controls
america yeah
so you know there's 42 percent they're
going to vote republican regardless
there's 44 percent they're going to vote
democrat regardless there's a couple
percentage they're going to vote for
ralph nader and the green party and joe
jorgensen or the libertarian whatever
but there's 10 to 12 percent usually in
the midwest rust belt they're going to
see this and say
i don't know
it turns out i was lied to and that's
you know why i think um
yeah that republicans are gonna
steamroll
uh in the midterms so we'll see
um but
i think
regardless if they do steal like what's
the outcome we're talking about outcomes
here
if mid if the republicans do
basically trample democrats in the um
midterms which i think a lot of people
expect them to do i mean that's just
politics yeah
that almost always happens exactly and
now republicans will control congress
we're going to be hearing a lot more
about this yeah so
yeah and the question is how do we
really get at the truth and you know
it's not an easy one to answer these
days it's and i'm not sure that i have a
husband but i think in a way it's it's
tougher than ever so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]